for centuries dog- driven sleds were a
Lifeline across the Frozen North
delivering medicine and other supplies
to far-flung communities today aircraft
and snowmobiles have mostly taken over
that work and dog sledding has become a
sport and a well-made sled is behind
every winning
team a dog sled race is an endurance
test for the dogs the driver and the
sled itself a good sled is both flexible
and sturdy enough to go the
distance at this Factory they make sleds
from White Ash a worker angles the ends
of vertical bars so they can be fitted
to the sled's top Rail and handlebar
these bars are called stanions he shapes
the other end of them so they'll fit
into grooves in the sled's
runner all the parts of this sled are
designed to fit together like pieces of
a jigsaw
puzzle a worker now screws aluminum
rails onto the bottom of the two
Runners he slides plastic strips into
those aluminum rails which gives the
runners a smooth base for Gliding Over
ice or
snow he secures the plastic strips at
each end with screws the crew is now
ready to assemble all the pieces of the
dog sled they attach metal screw eyes to
the runners they'll thread rope through
them when they're ready to tie the parts
of the sled
together all the parts of the framework
fit into notches made specifically for
them the location of those notches has
been precisely mapped out if one is even
a fraction of an inch off the sled would
collapse like a house of
cards they measure the space between the
runners to confirm they're perfectly
aligned and now tie the joints together
with nylon rope these ties are called
lashings and there are 22 of them on
this dog
sled historically l mashings were made
of moose hiide but nylon is
tougher they cut the rope with a hot
blade which seals the fibers so they
won't
unravel they tie the midpoint joints
together and the focus then moves to the
dog sled
handlebar a worker glue strips of Ash
together the strips are thin so they can
be easily bent
allowing him to curl the glued layer
around a u
form he clamps the wood to the form and
the glue cures for 3 hours it hardens
into the U shape creating the dog sled
handlebar he secures The Handlebar to
the dog sled with the nylon
lashings the team then assembles the bed
of the
sled they clamp the slats into place and
then screw them to the
framework they install the sled's front
bumper called the brush
brow next a worker cuts off the metal
bead of a bicycle tire and discards
it he uses the remaining tire tread to
create foot pads by wrapping it around
pieces of thick plastic and screwing it
into
place he installs a treaded pad on each
Runner to keep the driver's feet from
slipping off
then they install an aluminum bar
brake these pivot bolts will allow this
bar brake to be raised when not needed
and lowered to engage the metal
Talons he Loops a bungee cord on each
side of a crossbar and burns off an
end he hooks the other end of the cord
to the brake this simple bungee cord
mechanism will enable the dog sled mush
to activate the
brake he heat shrinks rubber tubing
around the base of the cord to protect
[Music]
it they now weave the back of the sled
using nylon cord to create a basket for
carrying
things it's big enough to hold a tired
animal the worker then loops and ties
the bridal to front stanions beneath the
sled he forms a v as he threads it from
the back of the sled to the
front he paints urethane onto the wood
and even over the lashings this will
protect them against
wear it's taken about 3 days to make
this traditional basket dog sled and now
it's ready to
Mush athletic footw we dates back to
ancient times but the concept gained
traction with the development of treaded
rubber sols in the early part of the
20th century these rubber sold shoes
were lightweight comfortable and hit the
ground quietly earning them the name
[Music]
sneakers design improvements have
broadened the appeal of athletic shoes
people wear them everywhere the athletic
shoe has definitely gone Main Street
using a hydraulic press this employee
forces a die through synthetic fabric to
cut out patterns for the upper part of
the
shoe at the next station he punches out
leather toe tips the toe tip is one of
numerous cutouts that add shape and
structure to the synthetic
upper after arranging the tip Parts on a
non-stick tray this worker places strips
of thermal resin onto
them she drapes a non-stick sheet over
the
tray then slides it into a hot metal
press the resin melts into the leather
to stiffen and strengthen
it another worker stamps the model
number onto the heel
[Music]
cutout then it's over to the sewing
department where a worker Stitches the
reflector on to the athletic shoe
upper other accent pieces call for more
intricate stitching so she arranges the
parts on a computerized
platform the platform moves back and
forth allowing the needle to do a
perfect job of stitching the accent
pieces to the upper this stitching would
be difficult to execute
manually once some of the more
substantial pieces pieces have been
applied to the shoe it's time to sew on
a reflective logo and the needle is once
again Guided by computer
software this athletic shoe upper is now
ready for its resin fortified leather
toe tip she stitches it in
place and then pieces together the
collar and sews it to the back of the
shoe she installs thick foam padding on
the inside of the
collar and then turns it right side out
to tuck the padding neatly inside and
hide the
seam putting on the collar has obscured
the top lace holes so she clears them
with a compressed air
punch down the line more computerized
needles embroider brand information onto
the tongue
panels
the next worker sews a liner and padding
to the panel again working inside out to
hide the
seam another worker then stitches a
fabric base onto the athletic
shoe she applies a rigid plastic to the
heel
that adds structure and support to the
back part of the
shoe further down the production line a
worker tugs the shoe onto a foot form
called a
last they heat it to make it malleable
enough for this machine to pull it to
the shape of the last at the same time
nozzles apply cement to glue the overlap
to the fabric
base then a machine Heats both the upper
and a Rubber Sole the heat activates
glue applied to the sole earlier and
also prepares the upper for bonding to
that
sole they initially used manual Force to
press the two
together and then the shoe is subjected
to mechanized pressure inside this
machine a rubber bladder expands to
force the two together for a complete
seal the shoe then gets a foam insole
with an arch support the worker laces it
partially and then pairs it up with the
other
[Music]
shoe an inspector examines the pair for
defects it is taken about 21 minutes to
make this pair of athletic
shoes and they should be able to take a
real
[Music]
workout